anreise ersatz des interviews für mich
ist wir wollen den geimpften ihre
grundrechte zurückgeben haben wir noch
nicht wollen wir aber und die frage wann
bekommen nicht geimpfte ihre grundrechte
zurück wird einfach nicht beantwortet
und dazu muss man klar sagen es gibt
leute die verweigern die impfung
auskurierten gründen
es gibt aber auch leute die verweigern
die impfung aus nachvollziehbaren
gründen
das sind auch millionen menschen über
die hat bisher noch gar keiner
gesprochen
das was im moment allen druck aufgebaut
wird ist natürlich nichts anderes als
gesellschaftlicher impfzwang da muss man
nicht lange drüber reden aber er wenn
man es nicht gesetzlich verankern kann
und wird dass menschen sich impfen
lassen wird es am ende in diesem land
weiß ich mich 15 20 millionen ungeimpfte
geben und die politik möchte nicht die
frage beantworten wann diese menschen
ihre grundrechte zurückbekommt ich würde
sagen der gedanke grundrechte
zurückbekommt den gibt es in deutschland
eigentlich gar nicht weil man
grundrechte gar nicht nehmen kann als
gewählter volksvertreter das steht
nirgendwo bei uns dass man grundrechte
nehmen kann
man kann in notstands lagen für sehr
sehr kurze sehr eingeschränkte sehr klar
definierte zeit harte entscheidungen
treffen um wie gesagt überwältigen den
schaden abzuwenden nichts von dieser
argumentation ist noch irgendwie übrig
nach diesem überwältigenden erfolg den
wir in anderen ländern sind das heißt
dass ihre argument grundrechte
aberkennen und dann gutsherrn artig
zurück gibt das existiert gar nicht in
unserem staat was uns da erzählt wird
aber das mal aus dem volk hasst es gar
nicht existiert jetzt sagt man auch noch
wir beantworten die frage nicht wann 10
15 20 millionen menschen in diesem land
ihre grundrechte von uns großzügig
brücke zurückbekommen da muss ich sagen
das finde ich einfach nur noch zutiefst
beunruhigend wie geht's dir damit die
grundrechte ich denke da auch jetzt
gerade auch im interview gesagt vor
allem an die kinder unter zwölf jetzt
wurde gestern beschlossen ok
impfempfehlungen ab 12 ist da die unter
zwölfjährigen bleiben umkämpft das
bedeutet für mich und das habe ich auch
gerade aus dem interview heraus gehört
es wird sich nichts tun beim thema
schule ist wird weiterhin auf vorsicht
gesetzt und es gibt ja auch überhaupt
keine anzeichen dafür dass seine
bewegung hineinkommt wie siehst du das
welche perspektive haben gehe ich will
ihren hat das gesagt man darf
grundrechte einschränken in ganz ganz
besonderen notlagen aber da braucht es
ja ein ziel also man schränkte er ein
grundrecht rein um mein ziel zu
erreichen aber die bundesregierung hat
keine maß keine ahnung ob ihre maßnahmen
überhaupt funktionieren und wie sie
funktionieren
wer beim thema schulen die bislang kein
treiber der pandemie waren aber auch bei
anderen dingen
ob menschen zum beispiel ins restaurant
gehen oder nicht die regierung weiß
nicht ob restaurant schließung geschäfts
schließung sich irgendwie auf die
pandemie auswirken
das hat die bundesregierung letztens
auch selbst schriftlich bestätigt auf
fdp anfrage
es ist ein solcher maßnahmen strauß
mittlerweile dass man überhaupt nicht
messen kann welchen einfluss eine
maßnahme auf die pandemie hat und wenn
man auf andere länder schaut die schweiz
österreich schweden sowieso mittlerweile
auch dänemark großbritannien dann sieht
man dort entwickeln sich die
infektionsquelle unabhängig von den
maßnahmen das heißt die bundesregierung
schwenkt rechte massiv ein und verhängt
maßnahmen von denen sie nicht einmal
erahnen kann
ob sie wirken und wie sie wird das ist
drauf gucken auf die infektions kurve
auf die inzidenz kurve von dänemark
einem also man könnte jetzt sagen im
moment die lockern ja stück für stück
und dafür geht es auch wieder ordentlich
zur sache in sachen corona der kommers
kurz zeigen wie sie da die zahlen
aktuell das ist der dänemark fahrplan
auch interessant das ist das was wir
besprochen haben also glasklarer
fahrplan während du sagst philipp der
wurde nämlich der deutsche plan den
haben wir bisher nicht mit daten
versehen das heißt bei uns gibt es
keinerlei antworten auf die fragen waren
geht denn wann endet denn die masken
pflicht beispielsweise dann können wir
wieder normal im öffentlichen nahverkehr
fahren ohne das ding tragen zu müssen
oder wann können vor allen dingen unsere
kinder wieder ohne maske in der schule
sitzen das ist alles in dänemark
geregelt hier haben wir es noch mal
klarer fahrplan aus der pandemie aus
deutschland hat keinen plan beste
empfehlung für schüler und studenten
empfehlung auch das ganz wichtig keine
pflicht mehr
man überlässt das also den schulen den
menschen vor ort das einfach zu regeln
man hat vertrauen in seine bürger und
das hat man eben in deutschland nicht
das betrifft auch beispielsweise den
ganzen freizeitbereich auch der ja nach
wie vor
bei uns eingeschränkt und vor allen
dingen großveranstaltungen da wissen wir
alle dass es da noch erhebliche
einschränkung geht vor allen dingen wenn
man gerade auf den start der fußball
bundesligasaison wieder blicken also hat
man das in denen punkte zu dieser
herrlichen aus meiner sicht entscheidung
dass man die ausweispflicht der
geimpften im herbst abschaffen will
wir sehen gerade in frankreich
hunderttausende menschen auf den straßen
weil präsident marco eine strenge
ausweispflicht verhängen will
wir sehen in deutschland dass man sich
noch gar nicht so sicher ist wie man
überhaupt unterscheidet oder wer war es
darf oder wer was nicht darf und welche
rechte der staat in seiner unendlichen
großzügigkeit vielleicht auch nur einmal
geimpften oder genießt man weiß
eigentlich gar nichts mehr
der staat springt mit uns um wie mit
verfügen wie mit verfügungsmasse und
nicht wie das was wir sind der souverän
von dem alle macht ausgeht und der in
diesem grundgesetz diesem wunderbaren
buch auch einige abwehrrechte gegen
genau solche entscheidungen hat dänemark
hingegen sagt wir wollen gar nicht mehr
wissen ob ihr geimpft sei zwar ihr seid
ja der staat ihr seid ja die bürger ihr
hattet jetzt die möglichkeit es gab eine
bedrohung
ihr habt ihr uns gewählt nicht wie ihr
euch und wir wollen euch jetzt auch
nicht irgendwie hängen ihr habt ihr die
macht und die verantwortlichkeit und die
verantwortung euch selber um das zu
kümmern was uns in unserem leben alle
miteinander und das ist gerade eine
panne bewegt aber er hatte die
möglichkeit euch kämpfen und das ist ein
großartiges menschenbild es gibt und es
ist auch genau die richtige politik
es gibt einen punkt der endet die
zuständigkeit des staates und das recht
des staates mich zu überprüfen mich zu
gängeln mir vorschriften zu machen und
das hat die dänische regierung
großartige region in dem fall erkannt
während die deutsche regierung immer
noch in der wahrnehmung liegt wir haben
es eben gehört so lange offenbar nicht
die infektion noch der letzte infizierte
befreites von seiner infektion und das
alles dauerhaft auf null ist erst dann
darf man dem bürger wieder zutrauen so
zu leben wie er es frei für sich wählt
wir sind bild und wie ihr liefert dir
deine news auf youtube zum nächsten
video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren